so what happened with halo I was so
excited to see your take on this I'm
still excited I I mean I'm you know I
think I look I mean in a nutshell to
sort of put it in his succinctly way as
possible
I got involved I knew very little about
halo same ways I knew very little about
Planet of the Apes actually when I got
involved and I kind of steep myself in
the mythology and began to realize how
much incredible literature there was and
the depth of the storytelling and it all
stacked up for me there was an
incredible foundation to the
storytelling so I was it was gangbusters
III was super excited in short I think
if I had sort of come at it from an
earlier perspective in the in the in the
building of it then perhaps it would
have gone differently but as a director
of a TV show it's quite hard to sort of
in a way become a creative architect of
a show and I think in a way I was never
gonna be that and and that's fine
because there are really many talented
people involved in that show who are
doing that job and so it became clear
that there was gonna be more time needed
and I'm talking you know some months if
not years to to align you know as you
probably know it's massively ambitious
so the budget for that needs to really
align with the scripts and they were
still we were still kind of working on
that but it ultimately wasn't under my
watch to be able to find that alignment
so there was a choice made by Showtime
which was essentially to push things and
if I had been perhaps the showrunner of
the of the film then I would have stayed
on that journey for two or three years
but as a director of a finite number of
episodes this there's other things I
really want to do so I was very sad to
have to leave but I basically it wasn't
within the framework that I had
originally signed up for
you